auf und davon mit immobilien
versicherungen und vorsorge
hague
[Musik]
so gut
ja ihr ziel kommen und dass
mitarbeiter
im haus
du hast dich ja
[Musik]
neue heimat florida micro stettler und
seine frau marina maria wollen in den
usa ein waffel restaurant eröffnen
späte liebe
und der partner philips weiter matti
planen in der toskana ein agriturismo
mit sechs ferienwohnungen
[Musik]
und aus dem aargau an die atlantikküste
bauernfamilie visa will expandieren
in frankreich eher wird sie einen hof
mit über 400 tieren und 240 hektar land
[Musik]
die tage auf dem bauernhof in oberhof
sind gezählt am
bürgerhaus
sandro wieser zieht mit seinem tieren
frankreich
unter sich ausgemacht
so wie sie jetzt sind es wieder
sehr stark als team waren
also darauf an zu singen doch
seitdem ich zeitlebens ruhig mal keine
habe ich
ja
zwei siebter sein den ich sage die
emotionale geschichten lebt die kirche
so zu sehen wird und das machen
dann hat sicherlich hatte ich war
einfach gut sind gut die leichte gehört
gesund sind
der hof von familie wiese liegt in der
nähe von aarau mehr als 50 tiere gehören
zum betrieb rund 18 hektar land erst vor
zehn jahren ist die familie in die
landwirtschaft eingestiegen jetzt steht
ihr hof kurz vor dem verkauf
[Musik]
alexandra wiese räumt bereits das haus
sie kam durch ihren mann sandro zur
landwirtschaft ich bin aushändigen
stoffwechsels fingernägel
alles aber es fällt mit gummistiefel
sind definitiv viel bequemer mit high
heels dass man immer gesagt es ist schön
mal
alexandra ist gelernte verkäuferin
an das leben als bäuerin musste sie sich
erst gewöhnen
sein bruder hat eigentlich schon lang
wollen unsere andere netze long wähle
der hat die auf neuseeland wenn dadurch
ganz klar gesagt nein so wie gar nicht
schmeckte zwei große hielt das ist
einfach herzlich wenig ja
und dann hat sich das einfach irgendwie
mit dem hof tage und so wie man ist
nicht einfach auf den lorbeeren
ausruhen
jetzt hat sich das
mal mitgegangen frankreich
ok
jetzt sehen wir einpacken könnt
schwind
[Musik]
auswandern heißt für alexandra und ihren
mann viel mehr als nur den wohnort zu
wechseln
sie müssen auch einen teil der familie
zurücklassen
tochter gianna und sohn sascha sind
bereits erwachsen und bleiben in der
schweiz
nur der achtjährige jan kommt mit nach
frankreich
[Musik]
im berner oberland hat ein anderer
auswanderer heute seinen letzten
arbeitstag wird so professor
michael stetter bricht den wenigen
wochen in die usa auf
spazieren
tätowieren ist mikes leidenschaft eine
passion die er abends und am wochenende
ausübt
denn seinen job als polizist wollte er
nicht aufgeben
20 jahren
durch
das ist
jetzt mit 44 will mike seinen traum
nicht mehr länger aufschieben und wagt
den neuanfang in florida
mit seiner frau marina möchte er dort
ein waffen restaurant eröffnen dafür
sind sie bereits ihre gesamten
ersparnisse zu investieren
nicht ewig und luftigen ort liebe
das ist witzig
nicht für ganz
lange fehlte marina und mike die
passende geschäftsidee die sie zum
einwandern in die usa brauchten der
zufall brachte den stein schließlich ins
rollen
wie ist das schön mit einer sparkasse wo
man im bürger- und
tischtennis
musikalisches werk in bern besuchten die
beiden ein waffe restaurant einer
gastronomie kette diese suchte
selbstständige partner sogenannte
franchise nehmer marina und mike
bewarben sich und so kam eines zum
anderen
im letzten raum geschaffen
aber das ist das franchise-system
natürlich hof und navas sowieso besser
machen dass man in amerika hatte
verstand 4
[Musik]
waffeleisen anstatt tätowier nadeln ihre
zukünftigen kunden wollen mike und
marina unter der heißen sonne floridas
empfangen
[Musik]
dusche
das war einmal
[Musik]
[Applaus]
im tösstal bereiten sich philips
kräutermarkt die und seine partnerin eva
dunkle auf einen neuen lebensabschnitt
vor heute tragen sie möbel von
unterschiedlichen ordnung zusammen und
die beiden wollen nach italien
so
rief er ist 67
trotz rentenalter arbeitet sie noch
immer als kindergarten lehrerin
65 und fresh pensioniert er arbeitete
bei der flughafenpolizei in zürich
auf die sache erstens kann man immer
alles frisch und
zweitens hat das einfach mehr stehen das
ziel gut einmal ziemlich sind daraus
future
[Musik]
der schrank dabei strömten trifft gehrig
und
nicht für 370 franken kauft
die möbel sollen in die toskana
[Musik]
die beiden möchten ein agriturismo
eröffnen die italienische variante für
ferien auf dem bauernhof
also wurde ich zu veranschaulichen so im
piemont gesucht
sehr wenig
davon
2100 franken mit dem nötigen schweiz gut
da
als ich damals einem zweiten ich schaue
dass ich einfach mehr kommen
ich muss schnell beschaffen
falls auch also bin ich unglück
verfährt zu einem lagerhaus dort
bewahren die beiden einen teil der
sachen auf die sich in ihrem bewegten
leben angesammelt haben
eva hat sieben erwachsene kinder von
drei unterschiedlichen männern
philipp hat drei kinder großgezogen und
lebt seit jahren getrennt von seiner
frau
die liebe zu italien hat philipp im blut
seine großeltern stammen von dort und
auch eva ist von italien begeistert
ripley abgebrüht und dann aber gesagt
jemand ist schon probleme hat ein riesen
nachteil dass schneider mehr und da ist
noch der mieter aber orientiert und
während das habe er gesucht gefunden und
jetzt gibt es einmal im moment
kommuniziert normalen schwer der hinter
ihm sind aber dann soll es
dann wirklich
bis kurz
vor
der wahl
2006 ferienwohnungen wollen sie anbieten
für bis zu 24 gäste coach wurde in den
höchsten
gang
wir verdienen
was erwartet eine runde bis
[Musik]
er hätte schließlich oder schauen was
gut dass sie nun überlegen gewann das
ist ein dunkler hand
[Musik]
noch geht in oberhof bei familie wiese
alles seinen gewohnten gang
die scheiße schiff begonnen
[Musik]
sandro hat von früh bis spät zu tun wenn
nicht in gummistiefeln dann in hemd und
sakko
[Musik]
nebst der landwirtschaft ist sandro
geschäftsführer bei einem
finanzdienstleister als betriebsökonom
hatte die firma vor sieben jahren
gegründet
thomas keller ist sant roos
geschäftspartner shows
1030 ein
schönes zuhause
wieder schaffen wollte es wird schon
untersuchen worauf verbaut hat ja
immer wieder für eine überraschung gut
und ich hatte schon mit heimlicher will
ich bin nicht da wo eben die idee oder
blauen gott also vor der grundidee
präsentieren und maximal auf die produkt
und schluss klappt es nicht oder
funktioniert sei das gar nicht so
wissens vorstellt hat
irgendwann sie immer der name lotus
renault ausgang was sie alles was ich
mache im ausland aber ja es ist ein
relativ zu werke gegangen dass sie aber
auch eine karten aufdecken und ja nicht
in notlüge oder die lügen verstrickt
werden also ja nicht merkt dass er ist
im busch ist also gemacht einfach ende
seinen posten als geschäftsführer wird
sandro wegen der auswanderung abgeben
[Musik]
die florida auswanderer haben ihr
gemietetes haus im berner oberland
unterdessen verlassen und sind so
marinas eltern gezogen heute feiert
marinas großmutter geburtstag
[Musik]
einfach so zusammenkommen das wird bald
nicht mehr gehen
amerikanischen
vater gedanken könnt und die bürger
offen aus der gott aus dem plan und die
wünsche
sie erfolgreich sind
ob damit eine milliarde
und die hypoxi aber die reden ja also
ich
mehrere tierarten hier wechselt
nur für menschen - nicht verrottet sieht
dass man verlieren oder zusammen sie
unterrichten hier und jetzt mit dem us
beamter ist dass ich als kapitän nicht
mehr größenvorteile mannschaft
sicherheit und
der
direkt
nach 37 jahren
viel und macht zu hause
mike ist nicht nur 15 jahre älter als
marina er hat auch noch drei kinder aus
einer früheren beziehung sie bleiben bei
der mutter in der schweiz
[Musik]
bevor es in florida losgehen kann müssen
die auswanderer nach berlin
[Musik]
die
diese war
dafür noch ein stück von andermatt
vorbereiter vor wieder
das konzept für waffe restaurant
übernehmen mike und marina von einer
franchise firma dafür bezahlen sie
monatlich eine fixe gebühr an die
gründer der gastronomie kette
du wirst du für mich schön
alte leute
das ist
dann zu arbeiten
haben wir war
also auch
soll es gar kein problem
jetzt gerade zwei wochen noch viel drin
hast du schon mal zum beispiel die
banane aufschneiden den regen rausholen
packten herstellen klose war frisch der
regel schon aufgemacht alles hinter
kannst du schon zum beispiel auch den
namen schon vorschreiben ok
muss gar nicht
rückspiel zu hause
trifft man ja das mini challenge sieht
laut
sehr geil so viele ganz zurück und
in florida wollen die schweizer genau
solche waffen herstellen auch mit poker
um opel
marina und mike übernehmen auch das
design des restaurants rund 45
lokalitäten dieser art gibt es bereits
in amerika sind sie die zweiten
die kunden können aus mehreren dutzend
zutaten auswählen
jede waffe ist anders da darf den beiden
keine fehler passieren
ich habe gehe ich irgendwie nach dem
raum
das ist eigentlich
los ist und soll ich denn wegputzen
ich frage mal ob es okay
die waffe wegnehmen
[Musik]
würde
super gau berufsleben
vor augen
mitte waren
dann kommt ihr und stracciatella eis war
[Musik]
auch wenn es noch etwas hart mike glaubt
fest an den erfolg ihres vorhabens
und das ist wirklich sehr
spezielles produkt was sie sagen
haben
[Musik]
guten appetit
kurz zusammen 16 bezüglich mal
ich habe mich fragen wie wir jetzt
vorgehen möchten bezüglich zucchini
tatsächlich
tommy
bin ich gegangen
hast du noch bis
[Musik]
in basel hat sandro feierabend
die übernahme des hofes in frankreich
ist für sandro und seine familie mit
vielen unsicherheiten verbunden
allerdings entweder du hast dir oder
nach einer
40 seiten und wo das muss einen seit sie
gemeinsam betreut werden
und insbesondere auch wieder als auch
längst dass der
der merkt dass das dem realen stimmig
ist dann ist das auch für die ebenso wie
steffi einfacher zum
zum verarbeiten und zum vertrag könne
als zeichen
[Musik]
man komme jetzt oben ziehen
in der schweiz hat sandro finn von 50
tiere in frankreich werden es über 400
sein
die ruhe zwei
nanometer der schweiz ist
sag jetzt mal so wenig will bruder
ja das ist gelebt in der schweiz nehmen
so gefragt also ich bin jetzt froh dass
ich muss sagen dass sie es
investierte kapital zu erwirtschaften
also wenn ich es gerne hätte
das futter für die tiere wieder selber
herstellen dazu hat er 270 hektar land
über 300 fußballfeldern
andere perspektiven also das ist flächen
sind vorhanden aber
wenn andere kepler motion auf dem oft
aber auch ganz andere kostenstrukturen
hat aber der brisanz erhalten am sonntag
natürlich ganz klar dass man
dass man immer ist eben abstand die
heimischen mit dem bauern betrieben
frankreich erhoffen sich die visas mehr
unternehmerische freiheiten dafür sind
sie bereit die heimat und ihr vertrautes
umfeld aufzugeben
und das bedeutet auch freunde und einen
teil der familie zurücklassen
[Musik]
zell im kanton zürich seit einem knappen
jahr sind eva und philipp ihr daheim
um sich stimme auf toskana jetzt ein
richtiger rosso toskana oder gehört dazu
die beiden sind erst seit zweieinhalb
jahren ein paar
das hält sie jedoch nicht davon ab
zusammen er großes projekt mit dem
agriturismo anzugehen
bewusst siehst du was mir natürlich
immer nimmer jetzt griff oder sand
das ist hessischer tatsache ist genügt
nicht beunruhigen so da war es auch
immer aber das waren wir noch bis zu
einem meter
lang und mit nur zwei jahren
machten ihre eigentliche gedanke als ob
es nicht
weiter gekühlt werden
muss
ja das ist schon
wir haben diese sind eine kanne klebt
und lustige wie es
ja manchmal
zweimal mit krieg und eigentlich relativ
lange zieht nach ein immer und dann
nochmal eine stufe das ganze ding dort
kommt
also der die bezeichnung für
das jetzt mit irgendeine beziehung
normal ich wo also personen nickname
dort das ist dass ich das ist wirklich
so speziell ist
dann haben wir es dann noch einmal eine
stunde und irgendwann haben wir mal
einen cheat so trafen da ist man dann
hat sie auf einer für zähler und
janina pro fünf minuten und künstlerisch
füße bei
35 oder sieben häuser und klaut sie
beendet da braucht doch dieses und jenes
und anderes
[Musik]
ob so vorstellen wie bei
den visa es heißt es abschied nehmen
tochter gianna sieht aus jedem
zahn und sie fängt aber im sommer das
studium ja
gewonnene kunden jetzt zu versuchen
auch der 26-jährige sohn sascha bleibt
hier er hat eine feste stelle als maurer
ganz freundeskreis und
brütet und sprache oder die chancen dass
ich mitmache berufsmatura
allgemeinbildung einfach mir gesagt
nicht gibt eine spitzengruppe ist aber
für mich allein
gestellt
die 19-jährige turner trennen bald 1000
kilometer von ihren eltern
weg
macht
es wahrscheinlich mit dem strich damit
mehr
[Musik]
apa
da ein business
objects geparkte geld adel safar monat
abonnieren
nibelungen
[Musik]
endlich geht es los in zwei stunden
sitzen marine und mike im flugzeug nach
florida
gepackt am richtigen ort er ja bereits
im vorfeld der tat geht es hier
in den junior muss in den frachtraum
der flug geht einmal quer über den
atlantik gut zehn stunden sind sie
unterwegs
[Musik]
rund 8000 kilometer sind es bis tampa in
florida
[Musik]
ups orte
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
aktuell kommen und das magazin raum jahr
werden aus
dem hobby ist ja ich werde zeit machst
mach dich auf zwang setzen
[Musik]
es sind nur ein paar stunden mit dem
auto doch in der toskana wähnt man sich
fast in einer anderen welt
philipp hat sich eine woche zeit
genommen er möchte letzte dinge für die
auswanderung vorbereiten über ein halbes
jahr war er nicht mehr hier
[Musik]
ein anwesen auf dem land gut 20
kilometer von der nächst größeren stadt
photonik entfernt soll philipp und evas
neues zuhause werden
und genau
das haben wir
bisher nicht alle schaffen
das ist es
mit
[Musik]
philipp hat einen termin mit dem
verkäufer der liegenschaft
bauunternehmer roberto hat die häuser
erst vor kurzem fertiggestellt
maklerin martina eine ausgewanderte
schweizerin vermittelte die immobilie
[Musik]
ein wohnhaus
sechs ferienwohnungen
und ein pool
dazu 18 hektar land auf denen sie
olivenbäume pflanzen wollen
bisher haben die schweizer nur einen
vorvertrag unterzeichnet der definitiven
kauf steht noch aus
das wird da ist es von hussy
und so ist
nun egal was ganz
dahinten
dass er 30 uhr dann noch einen
schweinehund aber
der dreifache königlichen ecke
das sport
maxi und haben mit lang studiert
aber ich denke es kommt
also was ich also definitiv sagen ich
würde das nicht das ist dass man offen
das video das ist das ist schon mal bin
ich meistens davos braucht und zweitens
ich denke wir werden hier behandelt
das jetzt mit dem rookie
nicht weil ich glaube dass
[Gelächter]
[Musik]
was sich jetzt mit schrecken verloren
martina ist dass du dass du ja das zeug
dafür kuchen sowie nach es vorgeschlagen
hatte schob schnell tasche
für bio ist
der shop stellt die show die show
sport aus
naja aber sicher nicht ganz das mini
rock noch gehandelt
ja
warum
ganz so will
dann muss das anders machen
ja
ich habe von anfang an gesagt dass mir
das nicht passt
es ist wahrscheinlich schon
ab braucht das mandat erteilt
[Musik]
4 uhr 30 in der früh ingo
bauer sandro und seine frau alexandra
bereiten die kälber für den transport
nach frankreich vor
die wichtigste romantisiert durch
den umzug macht familie visa in etappen
zuerst bringen sie die tiere nach
frankreich möbel und hausrat folgen zwei
wochen später
heute nehmen sie nur kälber und rinder
mit die milchkühe kommen in den nächsten
transport
sie doch
[Musik]
mit gehabt
hätten
[Musik]
14 stunden fahrt sind es bis ans ziel
einmal quer durch frankreich
[Musik]
und so geht es weiter
barra sandro begleitet seine tiere auf
den neuen hof jeder kürzlich transport
ist das größtes risiko die tiere zu
verlassen
natürlich auch dass es das skore in
der schule muss so john seinen freunden
adieu sagt
er bekommt dass ich für die usa danken
im neuen heim in florida werden für mike
und marina erste träume wahr
ihr zukünftiges waffe restaurant in
einer shopping mall nimmt langsam formen
an
auch bei mir schnell gut und das ist gut
und in der toskana lässt philipp bereits
800 olivenbäume pflanzen doch dann
fangen die probleme an der besitzer der
liegenschaft möchte den vertrag ändern
der verkauf droht zu platzen
[Musik]
muss ich ja nie
wo träume
[Musik]
kiefers 9
auf und davon mit der mobiliar
versicherungen und vorsorge